[Music]
we are here outside of BuzzFeed to show
you how democracy works alright this is
pretty much America when you see around
me right and we're gonna vote on the
most important thing you can imagine and
that's what's the best pizza
[Music]
we're only going to vote for three types
of pizza okay we got a conservative
liberal and independent that's what
we're considering here today so we're
gonna have pepperoni cheese and
pineapple for pineapple all right there
we go we got some negative feelings
towards pineapple do you know what your
favorite pizza is yes it's cheese it's
cheese all right so you're gonna vote
for cheese well I'm a vegetarian so I
like to keep it simple
what are you voting for you know what
I'm gonna go with a wild card I'm gonna
go with pineapple I want to twist yeah I
want to see new ideas being represented
pineapple pepperoni cheese okay and if
you like other things I'm sorry let's
vote
all right Wow okay all right you got six
four cheese five four pepperoni
nice twelve for pineapple at this point
guy should explain to you that this is
winner-take-all so everyone is going to
have to eat pineapple pizza alright how
are you feeling that you won I'm feeling
great I got the pizza that I wanted do
you feel it all bad for the losers no
they can deal with it okay pepperoni I'm
so sorry if you feel underrepresented
yes underrepresented okay so do you
think you just needed to get more
pepperoni people out here to vote I feel
like there's been a lot of fake news
about how you know good pineapple is on
pizza it's it's not an abomination so I
think people need to check their media
sources and put these two the pepperoni
people about like you can pick the
pineapple off and you pretty much have a
cheese pizza so let's talk to the cheese
heads how are you guys feeling about
your election loss like I may need to
leave the country
cheese is popular why aren't there more
cheese lovers here I think maybe not
enough people came out to vote today but
the pineapples you guys came out to vote
right right so you guys are kind of like
the old people of Pizza yeah absolutely
now I'm not kidding we're gonna now I'll
go in and eat pizza
congratulations she's representative to
you a piece of pizza
oh let's put the right way your
pepperoni motor it was everybody upset
about it mmm-hmm I don't really want to
eat this yeah but I guess I will yeah
reluctantly yeah you're damn right
because that's how the election unfolded
go ahead take a bite
[Music]
mmm oh you like it no well this good was
the pineapple falling out of my mouth
what did you vote for pineapples I'm
pretty hype about this how did you get
everyone out to vote for pineapple word
of mouth social media okay go ahead take
a bite tastes like victory tastes like
victory
so if you want your voice to be heard in
politics or pizza show up on November 6
or this could be your future
make sure that you show up on November
6th and vote because if not everyone's
eating pineapple